delivering food shopping for strangers
picking up cash seven days a week 12
hours a day That's Life from Michael
Garcia he's from Venezuela and has been
living in Colombia's capital Bogota for
two months after leaving his family
behind my father my mother my everyday
life has changed completely
am I your mentor yeah Michael uses his
mobile phone to stay in touch with his
parents in Venezuela he sends the money
when he can but it's not enough to
change their desperate situation during
breaks Michael and his colleagues often
talk about Venezuelan politics we hope
that interim president glider can help
us bring it in Carlos is also from
Venezuela he runs a restaurant here in
Bogota back home he worked in the
tourism industry before the economic
crisis he wanted to go to the United
States or Chile or Peru
but he ended up here in Colombia the
regime Falls but now I have my business
here and my family I need more time to
think about it I guess I'm staying here
for now
Carlos has figured out how to make a
living by helping his fellow Venezuelans
they relieve their homesickness with
products from across the border it is
all the typical stuff from our home
country it's like a little minute's wait
I feel closer to home this way it tastes
like my own mother made it
the casino is come on it tastes like
home I miss my country so much only a
few of the transplanted Venezuelans make
a good living here in Bogota most have
to rely on casual labor or the goodwill
of Colombians and almost none of them
actually want to be here
but the situation back home leaves them
no choice Michael desperately needs
things to change but as long as the
Maduro government stays in power in
Venezuela he plans to stay put
delivering food and perhaps finding a
future here in Colombia